You know, the last time that Republicans
controlled the House was 2011 to 2019.
And I think it's important to remind ourselves
the things that the House of Representatives
focused on and did during the time that
Republicans lost controlled the House,
because yesterday I did the segment for you about
things are very quickly getting very stupid in
the House now that Republicans control the House
of Representatives. And many of you wrote to me,
and I could tell that there was sort of a lack
of awareness of what things were like during that
period that Republicans previously controlled the
House. There was a total lack of doing anything
helpful to the American people during that
period of time. And forget about lack of helpful.
Think about the damage that was actually done by
Republicans controlling the House for that period
of time. Republicans in the House, when they
controlled it, voted roughly 50 times to repeal
the Affordable Care Act. Now, you could, depending
on how you want to slice and dice it in the ways
in which they did it. The number might be higher
than 50 or lower, roughly 50 times in some way,
shape or form. Republicans voted to repeal
the Affordable Care Act. That was one way
that they spent resources when they lost control
of the House. Had they succeeded, it would have
resulted in millions of people losing health care,
including people with preexisting conditions. Now,
thankfully, the repeal effort failed, but the fact
that Republicans were willing to strip people of
their health care should be concerning to all of
us. You might remember also at the beginning of
Donald Trump's term in 2017, they proposed that
other health care plan, which would have led to
tens of millions of Americans losing health care
coverage. Thankfully, that didn't become law,
but that was a priority for a formerly Republican
controlled House Republicans, when they lost
control of the House, systematically rolled back
environmental regulations. They withdrew from the
Paris climate agreement. They quite literally
took actions that worsened the prospects for
Homo sapiens on planet Earth. They gutted the
EPA's budget, making it harder for the EPA to
protect air, to protect water. But they were in
control. These are the things they did. They were
a disaster on immigration, including separation
of families at the border, caging of children,
although they could have moved forward on doing
something more permanent with Dhaka. They didn't,
even though they controlled the house and they
could have taken some of the credit. And then,
of course, on taxes, we can't forget the attempted
tax bills Republicans tried to pass but failed to
pass and also what they did pass, including in
2017 under Donald Trump, exploding the deficit,
large portion of the benefits going to the
top 1%. That's the record of Republicans
last time they controlled the House. And there's
sometimes enlightened centrists, as I call them,
who love to say, well, divided government
is good. It's good when one party controls
the Senate and the other the House so that nobody
gets too much power. It's it's meaningless pablum.
It's just something people say to sound like
they are thinking critically and moderate and
whatever else. When Republicans get control of a
legislative body, they do horrible things. Now,
when Democrats control have control, they
often fail to accomplish things as well.
But there's really no comparison here. And
so when we think back to that period of time,
it really serves as a disturbing preview of
what we're up against over the next two years.
Did you know that half of Americans are deficient
in Vitamin A, vitamin C and magnesium? Most
Americans are deficient in vitamin D. I take
vitamin D during the winter. It is sometimes
difficult to eat exactly the right amount of each
food to get exactly what you need. I just make
my life simpler with AG one by athletic greens
in the morning. One scoop of ag one. I get the
entire day's worth of 75 high quality vitamins,
minerals and whole foods sourced ingredients. It's
what I want. It's no more, it's no less. It's not
making any outlandish claims. It's just an easy,
sustainable routine. I've tried different ways
of taking vitamins. Ag1 is cheaper, it's quicker,
it's tastier. I'm not fumbling around with
different capsules. It tastes great to drink
straight with water. Sometimes I'll put it in a
smoothie or shake. It's simple. It's something
easy you can do. Going into the New Year, staying
properly nourished, athletic Greens is giving my
audience a free year's supply of Vitamin D. I
take that every day in winter. Plus you'll get
five free travel packs of AG one Go to athletic
green XCOM slash Pacman. The link is down below.